bonsoir à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
pour cette ce tout premier webinaire
consacré à l'analyse des enquêtes avec
rr studio est donc ce soir nous allons
commencer par un tout premier contact
avec rr studio pour un premier oui
binaire d'initiation alors une petite
seconde le temps d'allumer la caméra
voilà donc bon soir à toutes les tous
c'est un tout nouveau format pour moi et
je pense aussi pour vous donc on va
progressivement apprendre à utiliser ce
format là donc je me présente rapidement
je m'appelle joseph art m'arrange je
suis démographes de santé publique à
l'institut de recherche pour le
développement et j'appartiens à
laboratoire parisien qui s'appelle le
ceped somme population et développement
dans mon domaine je travaille plutôt sur
la mise en oeuvre et l'évaluation de
programmes de santé des prévention et de
dépistage dans champs du vih en afrique
subsaharienne et en particulier en
afrique de l'ouest
il se trouve que j'ai commencé à
utiliser air pour faire de la
statistique en 2005 dans le cadre de ma
thèse de doctorat
j'ai publié mon tout premier package air
en 2007 et ça fait plus d'une dizaine
d'années que j'enseigne le logiciel erp
alors juste pour vous présenter
rapidement à le concept un des
webinaires qu'il faut retenir et vous
l'avez ici c'est qu'en fait ça fait déjà
cinq ans qu'existe un site qui s'appelle
analyseur analyse r c'est un site de
support de cours dédié du coup à
l'analyse enquête avec les studios et
analyse est rare en fête a démarré à
partir d'un support de court qui sapent
introduction à air de julien barnier l'a
démis sous licence libre creative
commons qui m'avait permis de pouvoir
moi même complété avec d'autres éléments
et c'est comme ça qu'est né de cet
analyseur l'idée du webinaire est
vraiment de s'articuler avec le site
analyseur puisque donc ce site un site
qui va vous présenter comment réaliser
un certain nombre de choses avec rr
studios et les divisé en différents
chapitres dans la section manipulé dans
la section analyser et dans la section
profondeur par exemple si je vais sur
statistiques vivarié d'en analyser alors
le temps que la page
vous allez voir que vous avez un
chapitre qui vous présente les
différents éléments et vous avez au fur
et à mesure du chapitre le code r
correspondant que vous pouvez copier
dans le presse papier et ensuite ré
exécuté dans votre console
l'idée du coup du binaire qui dispose de
son site web dédié vous l'avez ici vous
savez ici le site du webinaire l'idée
c'est que les cessions vont vous
présenter un certain nombre de choses
que vous avez sur un analyseur ce que je
vous demanderai en fait c'est pendant un
live ou pendant une vidéo de webinaires
de ne pas essayer de reproduire le code
de votre côté sur votre pc
car sinon vous aurez du mal à suivre et
à réaliser en même temps l'idée plutôt
que vous suiviez le webinaire pour bien
comprendre le mode de fonctionnement du
logiciel bien comprendre la logique des
différentes fonctions vous pouvez du
coup poser vos questions dans l'espace
de commentaire à intervalles réguliers
j'essaierai d'aller voir
du coup les questions pour répondre à
des points de compréhension fera pas du
débogage où la résolution de problèmes à
cette étape-là et l'idée c'est qu'on
suit après une séance
vous avez ici son site web in her une
page inquiet dédiées à chacune des
séances et en allant par exemple sur la
session d'aujourd'hui
vous pourrez retrouver d'une part la
vidéo mais également des liens vers des
chiffres différents chapitres
d'analyseurs qui vont reprendre ce qu'on
aura vu à en session l'idée c'est
qu'après le webinaire vous puissiez
c'est de reprendre à votre rythme
les différents éléments et puis il y
aura à intervalles réguliers des
sessions un peu particulière de dit de
faq on ferait un webinaire uniquement de
réponses à vos questions pour discuter
des problèmes que vous rencontrez
ça c'est le premier point
sur donc du coup les questions vous
pouvez poser dans le chatt youtube ce
sont des plus tôt des questions du coup
de compréhension et bien entendu comme
toujours sur internet
je vous demanderai à si possible de
rester courtois les uns avec les autres
alors
tout d'abord pour démarrer ce que je
vous propose c'est que c'est
un premier temps de présentation de r&d
er studio est un peu de la philosophie
large et vous remettre sous les yeux à
quoi ressemble
r et donc là vous avez sous les
interface de la studio ce qu'il faut
comprendre c'est qu'on parle ici de deux
logiciels
d'une part vous avez le logiciel erp et
d'autre part vous avez
pardon excusez moi et d'autre part vous
avez le logiciel erp studio alors r en
fait c'est avant tout un langage de
programmation orientée vers le
traitement et l'analyse statistique de
données
il s'est développé depuis une vingtaine
d'années et c'est un logiciel libre sous
licence libre et du coût gratuit
ce un logiciel qui est multiplateforme
ça fonctionne aussi bien sous linux mac
os ou sur windows le logiciel je vous le
dis les gratuits et du coup il est
extrêmement puissant c'est un des
intérêts de ce logiciel là c'est que du
coup peut facilement l'utiliser pour des
projets collaboratifs puisque tout le
monde pourra l'utiliser
là vous avez ici si vous regardez r en
tant que tel c'est uniquement la partie
qui sur votre gauche
en fait r est un logiciel qui est un
petit peu austère quand il est juste
tout seul et donc du coup un des enjeux
c'est d'avoir une interface qui la
permettent de facilement programmer
il y en a plusieurs mais la plus connue
aujourd'hui la plus utilisée cr studio
est un studio est donc un logiciel qui
vous fournit l'ensemble de l'interface
que vous voyez là sous les yeux donc en
fait c'est une interface de
programmation avec le logiciel aird et
qui va du coup pouvoir nous faciliter
les choses on verra ça peut être à la
fois de la coloration syntaxique air
studio va intégrer d'autres outils avec
air pour faciliter des choses donc un
studio c'est l'interface qui va nous
permettre de travailler avec m alors
avant d'aller plus souvent quelques
éléments importants sur la philosophie
de verre parce que si vous êtes habitué
à travailler plus tôt avec d'autres
logiciels comme espèce est apte à ou
bien sas on habituellement à voir ces
données sous la forme d'un grand tableau
à partir duquel on va travailler
r c'est un petit peu différent dans le
sens où dont r on va avoir des objets et
parmi ces objets on peut avoir des
tableaux de données on tourne à voir
d'ailleurs plusieurs en mémoire et donc
du coup on voit pas directement les
désirs et que l'on travaille c'est
peut-être une des choses qui va vous
dérouter au début
ah on va le voir un des premiers
exemples ce soir mais r en fait c'est
surtout langage avec lequel on va avoir
dix et différents objets en mémoire et
on va voir ses différents types d'objets
qu'on va pouvoir manipuler sur
lesquelles on va appliquer des fonctions
et qu'ils vont permettre du coup
d'obtenir les données qu'on veut ce
qu'il faut aussi savoir c'est que du
coup ra ne fournit pas une interface
clip bouton là ou sur d'autres logiciels
comme espèce vous avez une interface
complète on va pouvoir choisir des
éléments dans un menu
ce n'est pas le cas pour m et donc donc
dans air en général on va mener des
analyses qui vont produire un objet par
défaut on va avoir une île où un résumé
d'information cet objet là on va pouvoir
les les rues manipulé de manière plus
précise au fur et à mesure alors ce que
je
un premier élément maintenant que vous
êtes très rapidement introduit r&r
studio la question c'est comment
installer rpr studio alors je vous
invite à pas faire là en temps réel
remet à je vous montre rapidement la
procédure
le premier élément ça va être d'aller
chargé le logiciel erp erp
il est accessible via un site dédié qui
s'appelle est retirée project d'autres
org
donc là vous avez ici la page web du air
products org vous voyez tous les
éléments et puis premiers éléments du
menu dans l'aude on vous renvoie sur le
cran alors ce qu'on appelle cran c'est
le complice yves un achieve network en
fait sûr qu'on va y trouver à la fois le
logiciel erp mais aussi l'ensemble des
package alors les package sont des
petits outils qui vont me permettre
d'avoir des fonctions supplémentaires
et tout ça en fait se trouve directement
accessible sur internet
donc j'ai cliqué sur crans
la première chose qu'on ne
choisir un miroir cran alors il faut
savoir que quand il ya des miroirs en
fait du site rend partout dans le monde
et donc du coup pour faciliter le
téléchargement notamment parce qu'il ya
une époque un air s'est développé à une
époque où internet était beaucoup moins
accessible
vous avez différentes versions et là
j'ai par exemple choisir une version de
craon qui est à très loin de moi par
exemple je choisir une situés en france
alors qu'elle
sur le camp vous emmène au même endroit
et premiers éléments on peut du coup
télécharger et installer air alors vous
allez choisir la version 2 r qui
correspond à votre système
d'exploitation si vous travaillez sous
windows vous avez cliqué sur air pour
windows choisir base et on va
télécharger la dernière version de l'air
en cours que la version 4.0 3 alors vous
allez télécharger ce fichier
d'installation puis d'exécuter pour
installer air sur votre pc
mais ça ne va pas nous suffire en plus
de r je voulais dit on va avoir besoin
d'eux est en studio pour cela
on va se
sur le site de r studio le site de as tu
diot idées à l'adresse est étudiée au
point comme alors air studio est une
compagnie qui propose différents outils
et en fait à la fois est reçue diot en
tant qu'interface de programmation pour
votre pc mais également une version
professionnelle et une version pour
sites web
nous ce qui nous intéresse donc products
on va les choisir dans open source dont
la partie qui est du coût d'une part
gratuite mais également en open source
et on va choisir tout simplement perçu
dion alors sur 7
vous proposait de télécharger deux
versions différentes de leur studio vous
avez un studio d'ex pape est celle que
l'on installe sur son ordinateur
personnel
r ce duo serveur c'est pour plutôt des
universités ou d'autres structures qui
veulent proposer une version en ligne
dont va choisir air studio dekstop ce
qui nous intéresse à la version open
source
il ya aussi une version joué dix
professionnels mais dont les services ne
nous sont pas nécessaires et qui coûte
très cher puisque c'est à peu près 900
et 1000 dollars par an à peu près on va
choisir d'aloisio d'extase qui est
gratuite et open source
on
alors on va choisir à nouveau la version
r signaux sexe l'ex-top free download et
là ils détectent normalement
automatiquement votre système
d'exploitation et on va pouvoir
télécharger le package d'installation de
r studio s'il ne vous propose pas la
bonne version vous avez en dessous les
différentes versions qui sont
disponibles pour windows pour mac osx ou
pour différentes versions de linux
alors on va mal
regardez rapidement comment se présente
la console r alors
vu les sourires studio donc du coup vous
venez d'installer est là on venait
d'installer leur studio et on va lancer
un studio automatiquement
r tu diot va détecter votre version de r
qui est installée que vous
ici à l'écran alors vous avez grosso
modo l'écran de la studio est divisé en
quatre zones
vous avez une zone en haut à droite
1 ce premier cadran au droit dans lequel
vous avez différents onglets
alors on les verra au fur et à mesure et
dont un angle environnement qui nous
permettra de savoir des objets
contondants mémoire vous avez un
deuxième cadran situé en bas à droite et
sur la gauche points pour le moment on
n'a qu'un seul cadran mais un peu plus
tard lorsqu'on va créer des scripts on
aura une partie en haut une partie en
bas et on va s'intéresser à la partie en
bas là encore une fois on a plusieurs
onglets un terminal des travaux qui sont
en cours ce qui nous intéresse c'est la
console donc la console proprement dit
cr alors on va
vraiment voir vraiment les premiers
éléments de base et ce qu'on voit ici
c'est que vous avez une invite de
commande qui commence par le symbole
supérieur donc ce symbole supérieur nous
dit voilà air et on attend d'une
commande et on va voir que dans un
premier temps ar c'est avant tout une
grosse calculatrice je vais taper une
toute première commande pour vous
montrer je veux simplement écrire 2 + 3
je tape
monde je vais l'a validé en appuyant sur
rentrée ce qui on voit ma commande à air
et air va me renvoyer quelque chose en
l'occurrence ici le résultat de
l'opération je viens de lui demander à
qui est tout simplement ça alors ça nous
permet de voir que pour saisir une
valeur numérique
il suffit d'écrire simplement avec des
nombres et puis on envoie un tout
premier opérateur qui est l'opérateur
plus qui permet de faire des additions
des autres opérateurs les plus courants
sont moins
par exemple si je tape week - 12
j'obtiens à -4 pour faire une
multiplient
bon on va avoir recours
ces risques ou les toiles comme dans la
plupart des autres logiciels et ainsi
14h25 vaut 350 et si on veut faire une
division
on va avoir recours à un caractère qu'on
appelle slash qu'une barre oblique
pencher vers la droite que vous avez en
général sur vos claviers à proximité du
pavé numérique ou sinon vous l'avez sur
un clavier français au dessus du symbole
de points et par exemple si je fais 80 /
9 j'obtiens ce résultat 8,88 on peut en
profiter
déjà pour remarquer que air et anglo
saxons en anglais c'est le point qui
sert de séparateurs de décimales alors
qu'en français c'est la virgule
donc soyez vigilents lorsque l'on saisit
des chiffres dans l'air on doit toujours
les saisir à l'anglais donc si je veux
saisir le chiffre 2.5
je dois taper 2.5 et par exemple je veux
lui additionner 0.5 et j'obtiens le
chiffre 3 petite précision lorsque l'on
saisit un chiffre qui est inférieur à 1
avec une décimale
on peut se permettre d'omettre le zéro
et donc 2.5 plus points 5 est
complètement équivalent 1 à la commande
avant alors quand on veut aller vite et
comptables certain nombre de commandes
parfois on va les récupérer une des
commandes précédente
et donc on peut utiliser les flèches
haut et bas pour revenir sur les
précédentes commande que l'on avait
saisi par exemple si on avait fait une
erreur et qu'on veut reprendre notre
dernière commande et la corriger
on peut aussi retrouver toutes les
commandes que l'on a passé à la console
sous l'onglet history en haut à droite
si je
tong les histori en haut à droite vous
voyez les dernières commandes que j'ai
saisie je peux reprendre une de ses
commandes et si je clique sur consoles
je vais l'envoyer à la console et la
possibilité de pouvoir la modifier
alors je passe plus
il ment de l'autre côté pour voir si il
y à une série de questions a pour le
moment
alors il peut arriver que l'on
une commande qui soient incomplètes
supposons que je tape 4 étoiles vous
appuyez sur la touche entrée
j'ai envoyé la commande 4 étoiles ar
mais air attend la suite puisque
l'étoile ici c'est un opérateur qui a
donc besoin d'avoir une valeur avant et
une valeur après et donc comme maire a
compris que la commande n'était pas
terminée ce que vous voyez apparaître
c'est le chiffre plus dans la console ce
qui permet de terminer ma commande si je
tape 3
m
suite de ma commande précédente et va me
faire du coup l'opération 4 x 3 alors ce
qui peut arriver c'est que parfois on va
faire des opérations plus complexes et
puis on va faire une erreur on va
oublier une parenthèse que ce soit
d'autre et on se retrouve avec un plus
mais on n'arrive plus 3 vous aurez ce
qu'on attendait donc si on veut annuler
la commande en cours a pour reprendre
tout de zéro sur windows vous allez
appuyer sur la touche echap ou esc pour
annuler la commande en cours
si vous êtes sous linux il s'agit en
général
de la commande contrôle c'est ici
alors autre élément que
t c'est que les espaces autour des
opérateurs n'ont pas d'effet si je tape
la commande 10 plus de 100 espaces 10
espaces plus espace 2 ou 10
beaucoup d espace plus beaucoup d espace
2 j'aurais exactement le même résultat
autrement dire le nom de l'espace avant
ou après une commande n'est pas
important cependant pour des raisons de
lisibilité du code et par la suite
lorsque vous avez commencé à faire de
plus en plus souvent des commandes à le
fait de l'étape et de manière très
propre est vraiment nécessaire pour être
pour avoir un code qui soit facile à
relier et donc du coup il est plutôt
recommandé de faire un espace autour des
opérateurs parce que ça va faciliter la
lecture notamment lorsqu'on va commencer
à avoir des commandes qui sont un petit
peu
alors on a vu comment utiliser hermes a
pour faire vos moments l'équivalent
d'une calculatrice
on a vu les principaux opérateurs plus
moins diviser multiplier j'en profite
pour vous présenter juste l'exposant si
je veux de au cube on aura recours aux
symboles accent circonflexe qui
s'obtient en feu en appuyant sur le
symbole puis sur espace et là je vais
calculé tout simplement duk pour des
commandes un peu plus compliqué on peut
aussi utiliser des parenthèses par
exemple je peux faire deux +3 et tout ça
x 8
ce qui serait
mende 2 + 3 x 8
mais voilà à
c'est bien joli de faire des de fer en
fait des calculs basique l'intérêt de
pouvoir mettre nos résultats dans des
objets et on va créer un tout premier
objet et pour ça je vais créer un objet
x et dans cet objectif
cet objet x je vais y mettre la valeur
2 si je vais dans l'environnement ici en
haut à droite
vous voyez j'ai un nouvel objet en
mémoire qui s'appelle x et qui contient
deux si je tape x dans la console
savament afficher le contenu de 8
si je tape la commande x + 6 eh ben on
va avoir tout simplement 4 puisqu'il
allait récupérer deux fois la valeur de
alors hein
un premier élément important c'est qu'on
a plusieurs opérateurs d'assignation
l'assignation c'est le fait d'assigner
une valeur à un objet là on a vu le
premier opérateur est le plus courant
c'est la flèche gauche et qui s'écrit
dans la console avec le symbole
inférieur à et en tirait il est
également possible d'écrire x égal 2 ça
c'est exactement la même chose ou alors
on peut le faire aussi à l'envers en
disant je prends la valeur de et je mets
la valeur de dans l'objet x et cette
fois ci je fais une flèche dans l'autre
sens avec un tiret et le symbole
supérieur a alors quelques remarques ces
trois écritures sont valables ceci étant
dit ce la troisième écriture ou mais
valeur flèche objet c'est une écriture
cotisera peu pour avoir une meilleure
lecture du code on vous verrez toujours
ça soit sous la forme objets flèche
valeur il faut vraiment prendre cette
habitude là pour éviter les confusions
l'autre élément c'est que vous avez
l'écriture x égal 2 ou l'écriture x
sèche 2
il est recommandé d'utiliser au
quotidien l'écriture exprès de nous
verrons un peu plus tard le symbole égal
il va aussi servir à d'autres choses
dans l air il va servir pour des
arguments nommé dans les fonctions il va
servir et montreux pour des comparaisons
et donc pour éviter les confusions
il est recommandé d'utiliser plutôt
quotidien à l'écriture x flèche valeur
alors maintenant que l'on a
à créer un objet ce qu'on va voir c'est
qu'on peut tout à fait créer plusieurs
autres objets je peux faire un objet y
qui vaut 7
et puis un objet je vais appeler fo qui
va valoir 32 et à partir de là voyez un
dans la partie environnement je vois les
différents objets qu'ils sont mais moi
oui on peut maintenant bas je pourrais
faire par exemple un calcul qui serait y
plus fo le tout exposé en x
donc là à ce qu'on obtient 1521 ça
correspond à 7 + 32 o car est donc
maintenant qu'on a des objets qui sont
créés en mémoire on va pouvoir les
utiliser pour pouvoir faire des calculs
alors il ya une peu
retombe sur le nom des objets les noms
des objets peuvent contenir des lettres
des chiffres mais également des symboles
comme le comme le poing ou enders score
je peux donc faire un objet qui
s'appellerait x1
y et qui contiendrait la valeur par
exemple 47
on peut
on met des chiffres je peux faire je
pourrais dire n 1 vaut 3 et n 2 vaut 6
par contre un objet doit toujours
commencer par une lettre je ne peux pas
faire un nom d'objets qui serait un n
si j'écris un n égale six voiliers je
vais avoir une erreur parce que le nom
un objet doit toujours commencer par une
lettre on peut dans les dernières
versions de r faire des objets qui ont
des nous avec des accents pourrait faire
normalement un objet qui s'appelle âge
et qui contient 5
les voiliers la jante
en fait de manière générale on évitera
systématiquement de mettre des accents
dans les noms d'objets alors parfois ça
marche parfois ça marche pas très bien
ça marche pas ça dépend de
l'installation
je crois que ça dépend si c'est le
premier ou deuxième caractère ce qui est
à retenir c'est on évitera
systématiquement pour éviter toute
erreur de mettre des accents dans le nom
d'un objet donc pour un nom d'un objet
on utilisera les lettres de a à z mais
âgées skull ou minuscules on peut citer
les chiffres 0 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 le
symbole points et underscore c'est à
dire le tir et du bas celui que vous
avez sur un top 10 français avec et
touche alt gr i 8
non que sur la touche 8 pardon sans
passer par alj r
l'autre
leemans et que air fait la différence
entre les minuscules et les majuscules
voyez mon objet x minuscule vaut deux je
vais créer un objet x majuscule qui va
valoir
6 si vous regardez maintenant dans
l'environnement
j'ai un objet x minuscule et un objet x
majuscule l'un et l'autre ne sont pas
les mêmes si je tape it minuscule g2 si
je tape x majuscule g6 air fait donc la
différence entre les minuscules et les
majuscules
c'est pour ça que dans un projet à
essayer d'adopter une convention pour
éviter vous hyper par exemple on peut
décider de toujours utiliser que des
minuscules pour nommer des objets pour
éviter d'avoir ensuite des confusions
entre les objets minuscules et les
objets majuscule
alors avant d'avancer je vois quelques
as
quelques messages
alors une première question
demandez crr studio se mettre
automatiquement un jour où faut-il
fréquemment télécharger les dernières
versions r est un studio ne se met
automatiquement à jour pour air studio
lorsqu'il ya des nouvelles versions au
démarrage des studios vous annoncera
qu'elle nouvelle version et vous pourrez
éventuellement la télécharger et quant à
air c'est à vous de faire intervalles
réguliers une recherche de mises à jour
mais généralement vous aurez pas y'a pas
de problème il n'y a pas de besoin de le
faire un très régulièrement alors jours
nos premiers objets ce qu'on a vu
jusqu'à présent
d'accord c'est vraiment des objets qui
sont très simples qui contiennent une
valeur unique sauf que ce qui est
souvent intéressant là attendez je vais
bascule en mode plein écran ça sera
peut-être plus visible pour vous qui est
intéressant c'est de pouvoir avoir une
liste de valeurs et pour ça on va créer
ce qu'on appelle des vecteurs
je vous fais un tout premier exemple
supposons voilà que vous soyez allé voir
un groupe de personnes
vous vous intéressez la taille que ces
personnes font et vous avez obtenu des
différents membres de ce groupe et donc
j'avais créé un objet que je vais
appeler de taille et pour qui un vecteur
on va avoir recours à une fonction que
vous verrez toujours et la fonction c
c'est ça veut dire qu'on gagne et donc
supposons que j'obtiens détail des
différentes personnes
je vais avoir un premier individu qui
fait 167 cm un deuxième 192 un troisième
173 un quatrième 174 cm et ainsi de
suite
on va pouvoir directement saisir la
taille des différents membres
donc pour créer un vecteur un vecteur
c'est donc une série de valeurs
on va avoir recours à la fonction sait
et on va séparer des différentes valeurs
par une virgule
or il est possible de créer des vecteurs
qui sont extrêmement grand je vais faire
un vecteur maintenant qui va avoir
on va rajouter plus de valeur
donc là j'ai un vecteur un peu
qui peut ces jeux
chez à l'écran sophie
taille à l'écran baher va simplement me
présenter les différentes valeurs qui
composent ce vecteur
ce que vous pouvez voir c'est la
présence de nombre entre crochets sur la
gauche ces nombres entre crochets
en fait ce sont juste là pour vous
indiquer la position des valeurs que
vous voyez sur la droite le 1
ici vous indique 167 est la première
valeur du vecteur le 18
vous voyez en dessous vous indique que
177 et la dix-huitième valeur du vecteur
simon avec
est encore plus grand
ou par
g
je rate chiche maintenant
levêque
un ton à
le 18 qui nous indique que 177 états 18e
valeur donc la valeur qui a indiqué
c'est la première valeur affichée sur
une ligne il faut savoir que l'affichage
du vecteur va s'adapter à la taille de
votre écran supposons que j'ai
changer mon écran pour être sur quelque
chose de plus petit ici en largeur là
mon recteur va être affiché sur trois
lignes mais les crochets m'indique que
167 c'est la première valeur du vecteur
188 la 10e et 165 la 10e 19e valeur du
vecteur on peut retenir c'est que si
j'affiche un simple nombre pour seul
dans la console hermes affiche crochet
1,5 et ça veut dire que pour air un
nombre tout seul c'est un vecteur qui ne
contient qu'une seule valeur
donc les vecteurs ce sont vraiment les
objets de base dont m alors quel est
l'intérêt des vecteurs c'est qu'on va
pouvoir faire des calculs un peu plus
compliqué je vais revenir un vecteur
plus court je vais revenir pour
continuer exemple je vais refaire ce
premier vecteur d'accord qui n'avait
beaucoup moins de valeur dont vous
montre ce vecteur l'ag différentes
tailles qui sont en cm si je voudrais
avoir les taille en m je vais tout
simplement prendre mon facteur taille
est utilisé par sans hélas j'obtiens un
nouveau vecteur avec mes taille en mètre
alors en faisant ça j'ai fait un calcul
est le résultat du calcul s'affiche à
l'écran par contre j'ai perdu le
résultat du calcul puisque jeu
à sauvegarder si on veut récupérer le
résultat d'un calcul et le mettre dans
un objet je dois impérativement à signer
mon résultat un objet par exemple je
peux faire taille m égale taille / sont
ici
je prends mon de
j'allais times rectorat qui contient
cette valeur jeudi visent toutes mes
valeurs par son et je mets mon résultat
dans un objet que j'appelais de taille
m si j'affiche l'objet taille tout court
lui il est inchangé et si j'affiche
l'objet taille m
il est ici si je veut modifier un objet
existant alors je vais simplement
réassigner sur le même nom d'objets
donc la terre
et d'un vecteur c'est que ce vecteur va
nous permettre de faire du calcul et la
voyez très facilement
j'ai pu appliquer une même opération de
calcul sur chacun des éléments de mon
victoire quand j'avais commencé à voir
plusieurs vecteurs on va pour faire des
choses un petit peu plus intéressante
alors
je vais créer un deuxième facteur de
même longueur donc là j'avais un premier
vecteur qui maintenant à on l'a vu cette
valeur de taille en centimètres
je vais créer un deuxième vecteur de
poids qui va contenir le poids des
différentes personnes
d'accord à
mais exprimé en kg donc par exemple on a
un premier individu qu'ils aient 86 kg
un deuxième qui fait 74 kg un troisième
83 un quatrième âgé 78 66 81
et 72 donc vous voyez
maintenant de vecteurs un vecteur taille
de cette valeur alors je sais que le
vecteur taille à cette valeur parce que
si vous regardez ici on blinde hic dans
la partie environnement est un vecteur
poids également de ces deux valeurs si
je veux connaître la longueur d'un
vecteur jeu peut l'obtenir avec la
fonction lines
si je fais lentz de poids j'obtiens la
longueur du vecteur points et si je fais
lense de taille
j'obtiens la longueur du vecteur taille
alors on a vu juste avant quand on
faisait taille / sans qu'on pouvait
faire une opération entre un vecteur
d'une longueur et une valeur unique mais
on peut également faire des opérations
lorsqu'on a des vecteurs de même
longueur par exemple ce que je souhaite
c'est calculé l'indicé de masse
corporelle l'indicé de masse corporelle
c'est le poids divisé par la taille
exprimée en mètre au carré je vais créer
un nouvel objet qui s'appelle donc imc
et je vais dire que cet objet c'est x /
alors
ma taille donc ça divise
pour obtenir ma taille en mètre et cette
taille
m je vais la mettre au carré alors voyez
bien les parenthèses d'ailleurs si vous
regardez bien ici
à
indique bien à quoi correspond chaque
parenthèse et je lance mon calcul
qu'est-ce que je
gmc regardons l'objet ims est l'objet
même c'est un nouveau vecteur de
longueur 7 et qui contient différentes
valeurs qui s'est passé c'est quand on
fait des calculs avec des vecteurs de
même longueur
les calculs sont faits élément par
élément 30,83 ça correspond donc alors
si je vous remets les trois vecteurs les
uns après les autres donc taille poids
et imc 30,83 cela correspond donc à 86
kg / 1 m 67 au carré 20,07 ça correspond
à 74 kg / 1 m 92 au carré et ainsi de
suite
on pourra donc faire des opérations
entre des vecteurs de même longueur et
dans ces cas là on ferait opération
ligne ali ou entre des vecteurs d'une
certaine longueur et une valeur unique 1
comme tout à l'heure avec tag / 100 eh
ben on a appliqué le / 100 à chacun des
éléments de taille
par contre
vraiment retenez éviter de faire des
calculs avec des vecteurs de longueurs
différentes
c'est tout à fait possible dans aer
puisqu'on est dans ce qu'on appelle une
règle de recyclage et vecteurs mais
c'est une règle un petit peu compliqué
et donc du coup à moins d'être un
utilisateur une utilisatrice avancée du
logiciel retenu dans un premier temps
quand vous faites des calculs fait des
calculs uniquement sur des vecteurs de
même longueur
alors je regard rapide
à quelques
sion il ya une première question quand
on a un tableau de données est ce qu'un
vecteur est une colonne alors la réponse
est oui mais nous verrons les tableaux
de donner un petit peu plus tard donc je
vais pas aller plus avant
l'apprenant mange on en est vraiment aux
bases du logiciel et aux bases du
langage
effectivement nos nos colonnes d'un
tableau données sont des vecteurs
et donc on me dit
comprends bien un vecteur est une
variable et je dirais non
un vecteur c'est une liste de valeurs
les variables dans une enquête
et quand on manipule du coup un tableau
de données d'une enquête les variables
seront représentés par des vecteurs
mais il y aura pas pire à plein d'autres
cas de figure on va représenter des
listes de valeurs qui ne correspondent
pas forcément une variable ce qu'il faut
retenir c'est que dont r on va pouvoir
manipuler tout un tas d'objets parmi les
objets que l'on va manipuler il y à des
tableaux de données qui vont représenter
des résultats notre enquête mais on peut
manipuler plein d'autres choses on peut
manipuler des objets géographique on
peut manipuler des graphiques on peut
manipuler des éléments diverses et
variées donc retourné un vecteur au sens
le plus fondamental c'est une liste de
valeurs
alors il ya une question un peu
technique c'est comment fait on pour
obtenir les valeurs précédente un
vecteur
je suis désolé ça les opérations dites à
fenêtre sur les vecteurs on les abordera
qu'au mois de janvier
là on va être vraiment sûr les premiers
éléments de base du logiciel
alors comment faire pour des données
est négative les données négatives
s'écrivent simplement avec un chiffre
moins donc si je veux un avec tu je peux
créer un vecteur qui va contenir moins 2
042 et moins
et donc voilà c'est les données
le mans a écrite avec le signe au moins
avant l'opérateur
et enfin il ya une dernière question
l2 pardon il ya une question de benjamin
série qui ne demandent comment est-ce
qu'on veut mettre une valeur manquons
danse avec ta on va aborder ça juste
dans quelques instants
enfin
qui est posée c'est comment démarrer le
logiciel erp et un studio en même temps
en fait
quand vous démarrez un studio est un
studio lance tout seul
le logiciel erp par contre pour que est
reçue diot puisse lancer le logiciel erp
il faut que le logiciel erp et été
installé sur votre ordinateur
donc en fait au début vous allez
installer le logiciel erp puis vous
amener à ça des logiciels et studio mais
ensuite au quotidien vous avez seulement
besoin de lancer air studio est un
studio va tout seul
trouvez le logiciel erp
alors justement on va
juste quelques petites opérations
additionnel déjà qu'est ce que vient de
faire nous fameux crochet vous souvenez
quand je taille
tapez taille j'ai un petit crochet qui
m'a dit qu'en fait que 167 est la
première valeur
en fait le crochet c'est aussi un
élément qui va permettre de récupérer
une valeur donnée si je fait taille de 1
j'obtiens le premier ray lema de l'objet
taille et si je fais tu ailles crochet 4
je vais avoir le quatrième élément de
l'objet taille et la semaine prochaine
on va avoir une cession qui est vraiment
consacré aux bases du langage on va
revoir les secteurs on va revoir
l'indexation les enjeux d'assignation
l'élite et les tableaux de données
vraiment détails donc là aujourd'hui on
va avoir plus tôt un aperçu du logiciel
la semaine prochaine on reviendra
vraiment sur les bases et je sais que
ces deux sessions qui sont pas forcément
les plus amusantes mais ces bases là
vont nous permettre ensuite de pouvoir
dans deux semaines aborder les
statistiques descriptives de manière
beaucoup plus sereine alors
si je veux avance
petit peu on va avoir maintenant des
fonctions on avait déjà abordé une toute
première fonction tout à l'heure quand
je m'intéressais à la longueur d'un
vecteur un vous vous souvenez peut-être
j'ai tapé lense de taille
de même j'ai créé mes vecteur avec la
fonction c'est la particularité d'une
fonction c'est alors les fonctions sont
des objets ils ont donc un non et on
appelle
fonctions en tapant son nom en ouvrant
la parenthèse et en lui passant des
arguments
par exemple assez juillet passé une
série de valeurs ça m'a permis de créer
un vecteur
l'efs c'est une fonction à laquelle je
vais passer un vecteur et j'obtiens une
longueur
mais voyons quelques autres exemple
supposons que je veux calculer la taille
moyenne eh bien on a une fonction toute
simple qui sape la fonction mine alors
r1 est anglophone donc il faut savoir
parler un peu l'anglais mais si je fais
mine de taille mines et une fonction à
laquelle je passe un vecteur est
savamment calculé la moyenne 175
71 c'est donc la moyenne de 167 192 173
174 172 167 et 185 mais on va voir que
certaines fonctions peuvent prendre
également d'autres arguments additionnel
et là on va tout de suite répondre à la
question qui était posée par benjamin
comment peut-on définir des valeurs
manquantes
supposons alors je vais effacer mon
écran d'accord je vais refaire un
nouveau vecteur taille
dont quelques uns
vie du un deuxième individu et supposons
que le troisième individu ait refusé de
donner sa taille en même temps je veux
garder l'information que j'ai bien
enquêté quelqu'un donc du coup on va
mettre une valeurs manquantes
les valeurs manquantes souza s'écrivent
n a majuscule en n a signifié note
valabre donc jeu
ensuite complété son vecteur 173 184 et
je peux donc j'ai une autre personne qui
a encore refusé donc j'ai une deuxième
valeurs manquantes
alors retenez bien ces n a en majuscules
il faudrait c'est important de faire la
distinction entre majuscules et les
minuscules et n a est une valeur
manquante qui va marcher dans quasiment
tous les comptes si j'affiche mon objet
taille
le voilà et si je calcule sa longueur
c'est toujours un vecteur 2,6 il y a
deux valeurs manquantes dans mon secteur
mais c'est bien un vecteur de 6
calculons à présent la moyenne
la moyenne que j'obtiens et n a est en
fait est une manière pour air de nous
dire attention il y a une valeur
montante dans le vecteur et comme cette
valeur est manquante ou ne peut pas
calculer la moyenne réelle
on a donc une valeur manquantes
cependant l usage ce que l'on souhaite
c'est calculer la moyenne
une fois qu'on a retiré les valeurs mon
compte et ça ça peut se faire
je veux faire mine de taille mais je
vais rajouter un argument nous regarder
dans la parenthèse 2,1 et là je vais
taper n à rm égale flou
et cette fois si j'obtiens
n 278 et 178 c'est la moyenne de 167 188
173 et 184 donc l'âge indique à la
fonction mine que je veux calculer la
moyenne
après avoir retiré les valeurs
manquantes et n a point rm pot n as we
move alors la petite particularité ici
dans la syntaxe c'est que j'ai passé un
argument nommé d'accord ici j'ai un
premier argument qui est passé à ma
variable mines et un deuxième argument
et j'ai précisé m
arm égale fossat des risées le nom de
l'argument et la valeur que l'on veut
alors pour mieux comprendre ça on va
regarder l'aide de la fonction mine pour
regarder laine du fonctions le raccourci
le plus simple c'est de taper dans la
console point d'interrogation suivi du
nom de la fonction
si je tape point d'interrogation mines
ça va m'ouvrir en bas à droite sous
l'onglet
out l'aide de cette fonction je peux
cliquer sur le petit bout
si pour afficher l'aide en grand alors
l'aide des fonctions se présente un peu
toujours de la même manière vous avez
d'abord un titre en vous dit grosso modo
ce que fait cette fonction alors il faut
savoir parler anglais
on vous présente le format de la
fonction et les différents arguments
qu'accepte la fonction et puis vous avez
parfois derrière des précisions sur le
résultat obtenu ou des détails souvent
vous avez des exemples et parfois avoir
des références
ainsi on veut ici avoir une référence
bibliographique pour la fonction de
moyenne en fait une adaptation à r une
fonction qui vient d'un langage qui
s'appelle est ce qui a été développé
dont 88
revenons à notre fonction moyenne alors
moyenne c'est en fait une méthode parce
qu'on pourrait calculer sur pleins
d'objets différents mais par défaut
c'est ce qu'on dit ici
elle accepte d'abord un argument qui
s'appelle x un deuxième qui s'appelle
jouis mhz et un troisième qui s'appelle
n arm x c'est le vecteur à partir duquel
on veut calculer une moyenne crime
c'est une fraction optionnel
d'observation extrême que l'on veut
supprimer parfois on veut calculer une
moyenne en sublimant 1% ou 2% des
valeurs extrêmes et dans ce cas là on va
donner cette proportion sous la forme
d'une propre d'une fraction alors on dit
pas un pur 1% mais 0,01
et puis
j'aime option qui est n a point rm égale
sens par défaut
alors déjà il faut retenir les valeurs
tout et files tout est face qui
s'écrivent en majuscules
correspondre
on va leur logique vrai et faux elles
vont
wihr principalement dans deux cas de
figure elles vont nous servir comme
argument pour un certain nombre de
fonctions mais également on verra plus
tard dans la semaine prochaine comment
est ce qu'on peut faire du coût des
tests comparaison et on aura alors dû
qu'on va produire du coût des valeurs
cloud ou des valeurs fall c'est à dire
des valeurs vraies ou fausses
si je reviens à l'aide de ma fonction
mines
ce qu'on voit c'est
la trois arguments x crime et n arm si
je rappelle la fonction mine sans lui
donner son avec des valeurs qui ne sont
pas nommés par
faux
là
l'ag
amy donnons aux arguments que j'ai passé
à mine dans ce cas là mes arguments sont
prévues dans l'ordre taille
c'est le premier argument passé y sera
attribuée à x 0 et le deuxième argument
passé il sera attribué à trim est faux
et le troisième argument passé il sera
attribué à et na poin rm un si jeune
homme mes arguments et on peut les
nommer sous la forme non égale valeur à
ce moment là on peut les mettre dans
l'ordre d'autre choix donc je pourrais
dire n a point rm égale chou x égale
taille et triment égal zéro à partir du
moment où l'on nomme nos arguments on va
tout simplement un rêve à savoir quoi
sociale à qui à quoi
alors la plupart du temps c'est un petit
peu implicite comme une fonction comme
moyenne en général on ne va pas nommer
le premier argument ou ceux là dessus
que porte la fonction je vais tout
simplement qu'hermine de taille et en
fait on va plutôt nommer les arguments
qui sont plutôt des modifications de la
fonction comme tout à l'heure on avait
écrit mines taille et na poin rm égale
faut et si vous y pensez ça fait à peu
près sens je calcul bien la moyenne de
taille
simplement avec l'option on va retirer
les valeurs manquantes
voyez aussi et je reviens sur le fichier
d'être que certaines fonctions certains
arguments ici en valeur par défaut
schrimm a une valeur par défaut qui est
zéro elle n'a point rmn valeur par
défaut qui efface et x n'a pas de valeur
par défaut lorsque un argument n'a pas
de valeur par défaut il est impératif de
fournir une valeur si je faisais nine de
haine arm et galt flou voyez j'obtiens
un message d'erreur qui me dit
l'argument x est manquant
donc quand un argument n'a pas de valeur
par défaut il est impératif de le passer
à la fonction lorsqu un argument est une
valeur par défaut il n'est pas
nécessaire de préciser est ainsi en fait
lorsqu'on écrit mines haye et n'apparaît
mygale clou je n'ai rien dit concernant
le paramètre rim est le paramètre crime
forcément on lui applique la valeur par
défaut qui définit nos fichiers dead
alors je vois qu'un certain
à
ont du mal à lire l'écran ce que je vous
invite à faire dans ce cas là à ces
temps youtube vous avez normalement bas
à droite une petite icône pour la
qualité de la vidéo est demandé à avoir
à être en 1080p c'est à dire dans la
meilleure qualité
si votre connexion internet un petit peu
compliqué dans le live du coup on va pas
pouvoir faire grand chose mais sachez
que vous pourrez revoir la vidéo en
haute qualité
après le live
alors dernier petit point sur les
fonctions vous voyez qu'on l'aide des
fonctions
il faut savoir que lorsque vous
travaillez avec a/r studio et ce quelque
chose que vous avec lequel vous prendrez
l'habitude on a un système d'auto
complétion regarder si je commence à
taper m e
exact puisque
ue herman me proposer différentes
fonctions qui commence
par m
n je vais étape et minent sa moue et y
met automatiquement les parenthèses si
je tape t as his et que je puisse il va
me proposer des objets que j'ai des gens
mémoire
je vais faire virgule si ici je tape
tabulation il va me proposer les
différentes
il sait que je suis dans la fonction
mines et donc il va me dire quels sont
les différents paramètres possibles
d'accord ici jeu
sourit suresnes arm
et donc ça je vous invite
l'occasion a exploré de votre côté mais
sachez que le fait d'être dans aer
studio
savane
s'ils étaient des choses pour pouvoir
pour pouvoir manipuler rapidement écrire
des éléments alors on l'a vu un très
rapidement pour le moment ce qu'on a vu
c'est comment écrire des valeurs comment
mettre ses valeurs dans un objet et
comment appeler une fonction ce qu'on a
vu aussi c'est qu'on pouvait avoir des
objets qui étaient numériques
1 on a tapé des valeurs numériques qu'on
pouvait avoir des valeurs logique qui
sont floues et fasse très rapidement
sachez aussi qu'on peut avoir des
valeurs textuelle et les valeurs
extrêmes se saisissent en les mettant
entre guillemets par exemple si je fais
bt y là je crée un vecteur textuel qui
contient une valeur et sa valeur textuel
cbt y
si je fais un vecteur qui contient à vis
recul b et ça je laisse tôt
un objet que j'appelle petit y eh ben
j'ai créé un objet y voyez il est ici
dans la console
vous voyez cette chasse pour dire car
l'acteur c'est un objet textuel y
contient deux valeurs a et b retenez
bien on y reviendra la semaine prochaine
lorsque on vous fera le point sur les
vecteurs leurs regards leurs
caractéristiques
les listes et les tableaux de données
c'est que par défaut un vecteur et d'un
seul type je ne peux pas mélanger dans
un même vecteur des valeurs numériques
et des valeurs textuel si j'essaie de
faire ça si j'essaie de faire un objet
qui s'appelle z qui va contenir 13.4
cloud et la lettre p et
cette obtenu en fait tout a été converti
en valeur textuel dans un vecteur tous
les objets sont du même type et donc du
coup là comme j'ai demandé à voir d un
objet sexuel dedans il ma converti
trouve en valeur textuel
alors une des questions qui posez c'est
est-ce que
l'air tout est vecteur non tout n'est
pas vecteur là aujourd'hui je voudrais
vraiment un premier aperçu du logiciel
la semaine prochaine on ira un petit peu
plus loin qu'il faut retenir c'est que
les vecteurs sont un premier type
d'objet dans aer et après on va avoir
des listes qui sont des objets plus
compliqué qui vont contenir entre des
vecteurs ou d'autres lisse ou d'autres
éléments
et à partir de là on va pouvoir
construire deux types d'objets comme les
tableaux de données qui sont faites un
ensemble des vecteurs
mais en fait on peut créer des objets
extrêmement complexe dans air peut créer
un parmi les graphies gweth des objets
qu un petit peu compliqué et en fait on
peut construire tout type d'objet dans
l'air donc les vecteurs il n'y a pas que
des vecteurs dans air mais les vecteurs
sont les objets de base du logiciel erp
alors ce que je vous propose
maintenant
être maintenant qu'on a eu un tout
premier aperçu de la console ce que je
vous propose pour aujourd'hui cette
sphère des tout petits un premier
contact avec avec les éléments et on va
voir notamment comment est-ce qu'on peut
regrouper dont commandes dans un script
en effet jusqu'à présent j'ai tapé mais
commandes au fur et à mesure d'accord
dans la console ce qui n'est pas
forcément très pratique et on aimerait
bien avoir quelque chose qui puisse être
bien plus bien plus qu'une commande et
que je puisse créer finalement un petit
programme d' analyse et tout exécuté
d'un coup alors on va écrire notre
premier script alors pour créer un
script dans aer studio vous voyez siro
le bouton +1 pour new file si je clique
dessus je vais pouvoir créer un nouveau
fichier art il ya plein de types maipo
moment ce qui nous intéresse c'est un
script air et donc vous allez avoir
maintenant en haut
l'espace vous allez pouvoir écrire votre
script est en dessous la console
inscrits
r
chez texte dont l'extension sera
d'ailleurs point air et dans lequel on
va y mettre une série de commandes
par exemple une série de commandes toute
simple peut être je crée un objet x qui
contient 2 4 8 et glisse je crée un 2e
objet y qui va contenir 3 et je veux
créer un objet z qui soit x puissance
irak
là c'est un programme et puis je vais
sauvegarder tout ça donc vous avez le
petit bouton sauvegarder c'est la
première fois que je sauvegarde ce
fichier là donc je vais faire un premier
fichier que je vais sauver
garder alors à cet été
à passer dans aer ce que j'ai fait c'est
simplement écrire un programme
maintenant ce que je souhaiterais s'est
exécuté ce programme
alors je pourrais tout à fait copier ce
qu'il y à là
puis ensuite
la console et puis collez exécuter tout
ça
pour aller plus rapidement
je peux me mettre je peux sélectionner
une partie du programme et cliquez sur
le bouton renault
le bouton one sa france que j'ai
sélectionné ici et ça l'envoi à la
console pour être exécutés et vous avez
aussi un raccourci clavier qui consiste
à faire la même chose colonnes ces
contrôles enter on pomme
enter si vous êtes sous mac pour vous
souvenir de ce raccourci clavier c'est
quand je reste avec ma souris 1 sur le
bouton rouge
il me rappelle le raccourci clavier
alors si j'ai sélectionné une partie de
programme ça va exécuter avec fran ce
que j'ai envoyée si jamais je me mets
jus sur lui alors je vais effacer la
console si je me mets juste sur une
ligne et que j'appuie sur contrôle entre
et sane exécute que la ligne en cours et
ça me met et ça même aux courses heures
à la ligne d'après
qui me permet de re exécuter la ligne
suivante puis l'année suivante
je peux si je veux maintenant dans la
console affi che z donc inscrite
l'avantagent du script c'est de pouvoir
regrouper toute une série de commandes
et par la suite quand on va avancer vous
allez crise probablement inscrits qui va
vous permettre d'importer vos données un
script qui contiendra tout le code
nécessaire pour faire le nettoyage de
vos données à la recodification et puis
on fera un dernier script pour l'analyse
si on veut exécuter tous les éléments
d'inscrits donc si vous exécutez
inscrits en entier vous pouvez aussi
cliquer sur le bouton
source sources ça prend le secrète en
entier et exécute les éléments dans la
console
alors quand on va
là on est vraiment sur un script très
simple mais par la suite vous allez
faire des scripts qui vont être de plus
en plus compliqué donc du coup quand
vous avez avoir un script qui fait
plusieurs centaines de lignes c'est
important d'arriver à dire un petit peu
ce que vous faites et donc du coup on va
avoir besoin de mettre des commentaires
les commentaires c'est du code que l'on
va écrire dans notre script mais qui ne
va pas être exécuté dans l'air les
commentaires commence par la lettre
diez donc ici je mets au début d'une
ligne et je vais tp diez et je vais
donner un titre à mon pru à mon script
inscrits 1
peut être fait au début du ligne il peut
aussi être mis à la fin d'une ligne
là tout ce qui est à la droite du dièse
ne sera pas exécutée
et si je fais
1 la ligne une ne sera pas exécuté et ce
qui est à droite du dièse surligne 4 ne
sera pas exécuté donc c'est des choses
qui ne sont pas du code qui sont pour
nous à retenir ce qui peut être aussi
intéressant c'est quand on a un très
grand script d'accord c'est de pouvoir
le découper en différentes parties et il
ya une petite astuce dans leur studio
là je vais faire une première sélection
je vais faire une ligne
je vais dire un création de x et y est
je le mets des tirs à la suite pour
indiquer que c'est une section
et puis
si je vais appeler ça calcule deux aides
et je vais faire au moins de quatre
signaux moins pour indiquer que c'est
une section
si vous regardez maintenant en bas
crypte vous avez un petit plan et je
peux aller directement aller d'un
endroit à l'autre
si j'avais eu un script bien plus grand
or la joue
fait des lignes vides et bien je peux
aller directement à un endroit on voit
un autre grâce à ça
de la même manière outre le fait que je
vous en permanence à quel endroit et
positionner mon curseur je peux cliquer
sur
six boutons la droite de source pour
voir le plan de mon script direct
comment éventuellement allié à un
endroit ou un autre donc en fait un
script c'est un fil
chez air qui contient une série de
commandes qui vont être réalisés les
unes à la suite des autres est en fait
notre travail va consister la plupart du
temps
à réaliser en fait des scripts
alors
[Musique]
guédé qui est de savoir ce qu'il est
possible de séparer les éléments de leur
studio dans quelle utilisation de deux
écrans je vous avoue n'en ai aucune idée
mais sachez que vous avez un site web
dead air studio donc si je vais dans le
menu dead je vais avoir un studio doc
qui va me renvoyer
sur un site web dédié
et du coup vous pouvez lire
et comment est-ce qu'on peut gérer les
différentes fenêtres et qu'est ce qui
peut être fait ici notamment on peut
séparer en deux ou trois fenêtres
différents airs studio
alors on à lui maintenant
on a vu un très rapidement comme moi ce
qu'on peut faire un premier script il
nous faut aborder maintenant la notion
essentielle
2 package est on
art du coup comment est-ce que l'on peut
installer des package alors une des
grandes richesses de r
ce sont ces paquets je vais package ce
sont des sortes d'extension à air et
chacune de ces extensions va apporter
il est bien un nouveau jeu de fonctions
est en fait alors les pages qui est
difficile de tous les connaître
puisqu'aujourd'hui on doit avoir à peu
près dix mille extensions existantes
pour r on va en voir nous un certain
nombre au fur et à mesure il ya des
extensions qui sont dédiées à certaines
activités par exemple l'accension à des
4o facto myners sont dédiés à la délice
factorielle le package survival c'est le
package de référence pour l'analyse de
survie on va aborder dix places qui un
package de manipulation de données dont
il ya un très grand nombre d'extensions
sachez qu'il ya en tout dix mille chacun
peut créer une extension c'est à la fois
la force de r est une des difficultés de
savoir laquelle utiliser à quel moment
mais ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que pour
pouvoir utiliser une extension il faut
l'installer sur son ordinateur
alors toutes les ex la plupart des
extensions sont disponibles on l'a vu
tout à l'heure on a parlé du cran du
compréhensive erard shit network et la
plupart des extensions tout cas les
grosses d'extension et les plus stables
sont disponibles sur le cran et donc si
une extension est disponible sur crans
on peut installer très facilement là
pour la suite de l'exemple aujourd'hui
vice nous allons aborder nexon vont
avoir besoin d'une extension qui
s'appelle quest ix honneur cautionneur
si une extension a notamment développé
par julien barnier qui va nous fournir
des données qui vont me servir d'exemple
dans la suite de nombres binaires et
l'extension cautionnaire fournit aussi
quelques fonctions qui facilite à
l'analyse de données
alors
je parle d'extension en français le
terme anglais c'est package vous voyez
ci en bas à droite
un onglet package sur lequel vous verrez
les extensions qui sont actuellement
installés sur votre ordinateur pour
installer une extension vous avez juste
à cliquer sur le bouton in-stat haut
par défaut il va vous proposer
d'installer des extensions depuis le
grand vous tapez le nom d'une extension
moi ce que je veux c'est kouchner
justement et je vais cliquez sur install
juste avant vous voyez le petit install
dépendantes 6 vérifier que c'est bien
cocher souvent les extensions besoin
d'autres extensions pour fonctionner et
à partir du moment où vous avez coché
install dépendantes 6 ça va télécharger
toutes les extensions dont vous avez
besoin
à partir des couches
ça lance en fait la fonction install
pour apprêter itx pioneer il est en
train télécharger l'extension est là mon
essence y ont hâté télécharger et
installer quand on parle d'installer une
extension ça signifie que air va
télécharger le fichier extension et va
copier les fichiers de l'extension sur
votre disque dur
par contre pour pouvoir utiliser une
extension il va falloir maintenant la
charge et en mémoire
donc il faut distinguer deux choses
l'installation d'une extension qui
consiste à télécharger des fichiers
d'une extension et le chargement en
mémoire de l'extension
donc on est ici sur l'onglet à kege vous
pouvez voir aussi un deuxième bouton ici
qu'est le bouton update ou update ou
permet de voir si parmi les extensions
qui sont déjà installés sur votre
ordinateur certaines ont des mises à
jour et à son homologue vous pouvez
facilement mettre à jour toutes vos
extensions
donc sachez que souvent il n'ya pas
besoin ou mais par ar souvent à jour
parce que r les mises à jour de herne
arrive que deux trois fois dans l'année
par contre les extensions ont
régulièrement des mises à jour sourit va
s'agir soit de nouvelles fonctionnalités
soient de corrections de bugs et donc à
intervalles réguliers
pensez à mettre à jour vos extensions
pareil quand vous voulez mettre à jour
vos extensions il est préférable de
faire ça sur une nouvelle session de r
c'est à dire de fermer complètement la
studio et de relancer un studio et à ce
moment là de lancer vos visages
revenons maintenant au fait que aquafina
je vous en ai parlé on a installé
questionneur directement depuis l'onglet
package
mais maintenant qu actionnaire est
disponible sur mon pc
mais si jamais je veux l'utiliser si je
vais chercher cautionneur vous voyez
cautionnaire est disponible sur mon pc
est maintenant pour le l'utilisant
mémoire il va falloir que le chargeant
mémoire et pour ceux ci on va avoir
recours à la fonction library suivi du
nom du package
donc à chaque fois qu'on aura besoin
d'un package donné il faudra le charger
en mémoire je vais envoyer la bot via la
console et ça va charger le package
kouchner en mémoire
s'il est un bon ordinateur et que je
relance une session de travail avec air
et que j'ai de nouveau besoin d'utiliser
coactionnaires il faudra à nouveau que
je lance la commande laborie aux
actionnaires autrement dit la première
chose que l'on mettra toujours au début
d'un script c'est une série de library
pour charger les package dont on aura
besoin pour ce script là où pour cette
analyse là et pourquoi est ce qu'on vous
le demande à chaque fois c'est parce que
si on chargeait tous les paquets john et
moi on serait pas du tout petit mâle en
mémoire et ça ferait trop de choses à
gérer donc c'est pour ça que en fait air
part du principe que vous ne charge au
but à chaque fois que ce que vous avez
besoin
alors l'intérêt ici d'avoir le package
collectionneurs c'est qui va nous servir
ce soir pour un premier exemple est un
tout premier exemple de ce que c'est
qu'un tableau de données alors nous
verrons la semaine prochaine comment
est-ce que l'on peut importer ses
propres données
parce qu'en général on va pas taper ces
données à la main on va les récupérer et
d'ailleurs mais souvent que ce soit pour
les cours que ce soit pour des exemples
dans les fonctions on va utiliser des
données qui sont déjà fourni dans l'air
ou qui sont fournies par un package et
là on va charger des données qui
s'appelle hdv 2003 alors la fonction
data c'est une fonction qui permet de
charger des données d'exemples qui sont
fournis et à gvt et 2003
ce sont des données qui sont fournies
par quest ix honneur alors quand je
tap la commande data hdv 2003 voyez un
jeu les mis dans mon script et je les
envoyer à la console ça a chargé en
mémoire un nouvel objet qui s'appelle
hdv 2003 et c'est un objet de type
tableau de données la semaine prochaine
nous reverrons détails qu'est ce qu'un
vecteur
qu'est ce qu'une liste et qu'est ce
qu'un tableau de données mais les
tableaux de données
c'est ce qu'on va utiliser le plus
souvent puisque c'est vraiment format
que vous connaissez de tableau avec des
observations en ligne et des variables
en colonne en l'occurrence l'objet hdv
2003 est un tableau qui contient demi
observations 2 invariable
si vous avez besoin de visualiser ce
tableau c'est possible dans un studio
vous voyez que à côté du nom de l'objet
il ya un petit une petite icône en forme
de tableur si je clique dessus ça va
m'ouvrir un tableur me permettant de
visualiser m'est donnée je ne peux pas
modifier les données c'est uniquement un
tableur de visualisation mais je peux
voir du coup les différentes
observations les différentes colonnes et
mes différentes variables
vous avez ici un une option qui
s'appelle silver si je l'activent ça me
permet de pouvoir s'ils traînent pas
remis de mes données par exemple je
voudrais uniquement les individus qui
ont entre 25 et
49 ans et donc la gérer
voir qu'une partie je peut filtrer
uniquement les hommes
donc vous avez ici des outils qui vont
vous permettre de pouvoir explorer les
données
alors
une autre manière de voir les données
d'accord c'est dans la console de taper
directement le nom de l'objet
si je tape hdv 2003 air va vouloir
m'afficher mes données mais voyez c'est
pas du tout pratique notamment pour un
tableau aussi grand avec autant
d'éléments
on va donc avoir recours à d'autres
fonctions pour pouvoir les regarder une
fonction de base dans l'air ça la
fonction esther str ça veut dire ce
procter et c'est un peu de voir comment
un objet organisée si je le fais sur mon
tableau de données hdv 2003 fameux père
de voir que c'est un tableau de données
ou data forem dans air de 2000
observations avec 20 variable et j'ai
ici ma liste des variables là on va voir
ce boxeur est pas toujours là l'outil le
plus simple pour regarder des tableaux
de données un peu complexe
si avoir recours à une autre fonction
bien pratique et qui disponible donc aux
actionnaires
c'est la fonction look fort fort de hdv
ça
j'ai un petit tableau de mes différentes
variables
là on me dit que j'ai une première
variable qui s'appelle idée c'est une
colonne de type entier india gars avec
des valeurs qui vont de 1 à 2000 j'ai la
troisième variable s'appelle saxe une
colonne de type facteurs nous verrons la
semaine prochaine plus précisément ce
que sont les facteurs avec deux valeurs
possibles qui sont hommes et femmes et
ça c'est une variable du coup
qualitative l'avantagent de look forcée
si quand on a là vous avez un talbot
avec mon vin variable ça va mais parfois
vous allez importer les données une
grosse enquête et vous retrouver qu'un
tableau avec 200 ou 300 variable
l'intérêt ce look fort c'est qu'on peut
lui donner un élément de recherche
recherche - toutes les variables dans
lesquels on va trouver br dans le nom de
la variable
claude faure à gvt et 2003 une chaîne de
recherche va me permettre de voir
uniquement une petite partie 1 est de
rechercher plus facilement dans mon
tableau
alors le lundi
rés
d'un lac
et d'un tableau de donner un ça va être
taxé d eau variable c'est une des
questions qui étaient posées tout à
l'heure c'est est ce que mes variables
sont des vecteurs
oui la particularité d'un tableau de
données c'est qu'en fait chacune des
variables correspond à un vecteur
différent et on peut accéder à ses
valeurs avec le symbole dollars
par exemple on a vu une des variables de
mon tableau s'appelle âge
d'accord et si je veux avoir accès à la
variable age 2 hdv 2003 je peux taper
hdv 2003 dollars âge cette écriture
je veux la variable âge du tableau hdv
2003 alors si je la fiche à l'écran
voyez ça fait beaucoup de données c'est
pas forcément très pratique
par contre je peux calculer un âge moyen
est donc la commande mines entre
parenthèses
hdv 2003 dollars âge me permet de
calculer mon âge moyen
alors s'il ya quelques cas
alors première question quand
j'avais 2003 il me dit que le jeu de
données est introuvable pour que la
fonction fonctionne vous devez avoir
auparavant chargé questionnaire encore
une fois je vous rappelle je vous invite
vraiment pur moment à suivre le
webinaire puis ici de refaire les
commandes en suivant les chapitres à
l'isère chez vous quand vous serez au
calme autre question est ce que les
fonctions look fort et str sont des
fonctions du package pioneer alors str
c'est une fonction de base dans aer et
qui marche sur tout type d'objet donc
c'est une fonction fondamentale qui
demeurent de voir la structure d'un
objet quel qu'il soit je pourrais je
crois même le faire par exemple sur une
fonction si je fais str de mines je vais
avoir la structure l'objet mines
il va me dire c'est une fonction la
fonction
look for par contre c'est effectivement
une fonction du package questionnaire
donc si on n'a pas fait la grille
coactionnaire abandonné qu'on n'a pas
chargé package fonctionnaires on n'aura
pas accès à la fonction look fort
alors c'est un tout petit peu plus
subtil en fait la fonction look fort ces
suppressions
une fonction qui vient du package label
d' et qui aurait importé par le paquet
du questionnaire
est-ce que la fonction look fort ne peut
être utilisé que pour les données qui
viennent du package point éphémère
pas du tout look fort peut être utilisé
sur n'importe quel type de tableaux de
données
on reviendra un peu plus tard on
reviendra un petit peu plus tard sur
comment à la semaine prochaine on verra
comment on peut importer nos données et
qu'ils aient d'autres d'autres tableaux
de données
mais je vais vous donner un exemple
rapide il ya un tableau de données qui
toujours accessible dans air il
s'appelle ifis d'accord d'en tirer c'est
un tableau de données qui vous donne la
longueur des pétales et des sépales de
différent de différence iris c'est un
tableau qu'on trouve beaucoup dans les
exemples iris est aussi un tableau de
données et je peux utiliser le look fort
avec
legré iris et lui dire qu est-ce qui
contient des lettres
l e
donc retenait look fort ça marche avec
n'importe quel tableau de données
alors comment
est ce qu'on peut faire pour savoir à
quel package correspondent commandes
donné d'accord alors je ne sais plus
laquelle package correspond au look fort
on a deux possibilités
les gens on va voir comment est ce qu'on
peut faire une recherche dans l'aide
d'accord on a vu que pour regarder
l'aide d'une fonction c'était point
d'interrogation nom de la fonction on
peut faire une recherche dans l'aide de
tous les packs qui sont actuellement
installé sur son ordinateur
dans ce cas là on va faire un double
point d'interrogation et je tapais mon
coup fort
si je fais ça alors ça prend toujours
quelques secondes air va rechercher dans
tous les fichiers dead
des package qui sont installés sur mon
ordinateur et sans que j'en ai beaucoup
parce que j'en fais j'en fais pas mal
et à ce moment là
à il va me trouver et il m'a trouve la
fonction look fort dans le package la
bad et d'un questionnaire en fait ce qui
se passe c'est parce que donc aux
actionnaires
en fait look fort et réexporter d'un
autre package qui est la belle d' il se
trouve que quand vous installez
cautionnaire la belle va être
automatiquement installés en même temps
que quoi ce n'est par contre si jamais
on ne sait pas aussi on cherche une
fonction qui est dans un paquet qu'on
n'a pas encore installé alors on a
quelques possibilités
déjà on peut retourner sur le site
analyse r donc je vous rappelle le site
analyse r1 il est accessible à l'adresse
l'art marange point github points ivo
slash analyseur quand vous allez sur le
site analyseur vous avez en eau dans le
menu index et un index des fonctions si
je vais dans l'index des fonctions je
peux aller sur la lettre elle
et je mets
son look fort là on me dit que la
fonction look fort du package label on
en parle dans trois chapitres qui sont
visualisées ces données lissées tableaux
de données facteur et vecteur labellisés
alors vous pouvez peut-être un peu
conçues avec le fait qu'on parle aussi
d'un look fort d'un questionnaire look
fort avec le under score ou look fort
attaché c'est la même fonction c'est
juste qu'elle est disponible dans les
deux orthographes est en fait cette
fonction-là est disponible à la fois
d'un package label d' ouvert à la
semaine prochaine et dans ta caisse
cautionneur il ya certaines fonctions
comme ça qui sont un peu basique qui
sont reprises de pâques est un package
et qui du coup sont accessibles dans
plusieurs endroits différents
si on se pose une autre question et
qu'on sait plus où regarder
alors vous pouvez aller faire une
recherche qui sera sexy on fait une
recherche sur google on a des chances
d'avoir des résultats qui correspondent
pas aux logiciels erp et donc pour avoir
une recherche plus efficace
le mieux est d'aller sur le site r6 mrs
eux eu qu'à point org
l'intérêt du site r6 on sait qu'on va
faire des recherches qui sont
directement
spécifique aux logiciels erp donc par
exemple si alors vaut mieux poser sa
question en anglais 1 mais par exemple à
gévezé savoir comment calculer une
médiane je peux taper médium et à ce
moment là on va me renvoyer plusieurs
éléments et qui sont tous en lien que
logiciel erp on voit d'ailleurs que le
premier élément qu'on me renvoie c'est
la fonction médiane du package air
documentation ça me permet de vous
présenter le site web
r documentation le site air
documentation c'est un site qui reprend
la documentation des package de air et
de l'ensemble des package et donc du
coup je peux faire une recherche
j' y compris sur des package que je n'ai
pas installé si je fais une recherche
sur look fort
eh bien il va voir son nez sur site r
documentation ah mais j'ai une fonction
look fort dans le package label on en
parle aussi dans d'autres endroits de
documentation et voyez déjà juste en
tapant look riva me trouve il va
commencer à trouver des on voit qu'il ya
une fonction look fort dans l'appel
il existe une fonction look for va
s'absenter in furness dans le package
climber et vous avez trouvé tout un
résultat dans différents objets donc en
fait où trouver de l'information on peut
faire on l'a vu une recherche dans la
documentation g localement on peut faire
une recherche dans l'index des fonctions
sur le site analyse air et comme tout ce
que je vais vous présenter repart des
supports de cours d'un analyseur ça peut
être un bon point d'entrée
sinon pour une recherche plus générale
vous avez le site web et recyc point org
et enfin vous avez ensuite le package
air documentation mais ça va nous
permettre d'aborder une question un peu
plus général qui est de savoir au final
où peut-on trouver de l'aide
alors je vous renvoie
rana l'isère
un des chapitres dans le menu manipuler
prise en main vous avez un chapitre
entier qui s'intitule où trouver de
l'aide
sachez qu'il existe et du co vous
pourrez revenir à ce chapitre là dès
lors que vous avez besoin vous
recherchez un terme de ressources
par exemple on vous rappelle comment
fonctionne l'aide sur une fonction
comment on peut naviguer dans l'aide on
vous présente le moteur de recherche r6
on vous renvoie sur les sites web
r documentation et rdr y hockey
l'équivalent de r documentation vous
avez aussi on les abordera un peu plus
tard sur certains package des antisèches
bien pratique qui permet d'avoir un
petit document imprimé avoir sous la
main pour retrouver les principales
fonctions d'un package vous avez aussi
des renvois vers les ressources plus
officielle vers des ouvrages et des
blogs francophones ou anglophones
donc en fait
mal de ressources qui existent sur air
vous pouvez présentent pas toutes
maintenant mais sachez que vous aurez
plus du coup de détails sur le chapiteau
trouver de l'aide sur analyseur vous
avez aussi une section qui vous parle de
nous poser des questions alors déjà
premier lieu en bas de chaque page sur
analyse est tout en bas vous voyez un
espace de commentaire vous pouvez du
coup poser vos questions sur un
analyseur et du coup j'essaierai d'y
répondre en fonction des disponible en
général sous un ou deux jours d'ailleurs
je vous invite toutes et tous à ne pas
envoyer des emails en direct mais plutôt
à poser des questions dans l'espace de
discussion
d'une part parce que je ne peux pas
répondre à toutes les questions
individuelles dans les mails direct
alors que quand vous les posez dans
l'espace de discussion
les réponses du coup bénéficie à tout le
monde puisqu'on est dans un espace du
coup public
vous avez aussi d'autres endroits pour
ceux qui préfèrent plutôt des
discussions instantanées sachez que sur
ce lac
il ya un groupe francophone qui
s'appelle heureux dans lesquels vous
pouvez du coup discuter vous avez aussi
une liste de discussion qui s'appelle et
rock et qui dédiez barré par et nater
kenizé discussions pour pour échanger
autour de l'utilisation de r en sciences
sociales et vous avez aussi la liste
mailing list par deux qui existent quand
ea qui est plus généralement d'ailleurs
en statistiques et qui autour de
l'enseignement et des preuves d' analyse
quantitative en sciences sociales
sachez après qui a encore d'autres
canaux en fonction de ce que vous
appréciez yade aux petits de discussion
où il ya des canaux irc pour ceux qui
qui qui sont intéressés et enfin sachez
qu'il ya encore d'autres ressources que
vous pouvez trouver en particulier une
page intéressante qui la page
wren chi est clean pages qui essayent de
lister des ressources pédagogiques sur
air en français ainsi que des cours en
ligne vous voyez en fait il ya pas mal
d'endroits où on peut trouver de
l'information autour de r oui on va
pouvoir trouver des éléments sur
commande données après vous inquiétez
pas un avec usage au bout d'un moment on
finit par savoir où trouver
l'information et puis surtout on connaît
les quelques et quelques paquets de
particuliers qui vont nous être
particulièrement utile pour ce qu'on
fait
alors ce que je
on va avoir deux dernières petites
choses avant de vous quitter ce soir
parce que ça fait déjà beaucoup de
choses hein pour un tout premier une
toute première journée rapidement je
veux vous je veux vous parler du tailles
diverses
alors comme je voulais dire il ya
énormément de package différents sur eux
et du coup il ya plein de manières
différentes de faire les mêmes choses et
parfois on peut faire les mêmes choses
de différentes manières sous différentes
philosophies
par exemple si on veut faire des
graphiques il ya trois grandes familles
de fret trafic des fonctions historiques
de graphiques de r ce qu'on appelle le
rba il ya des gens qui sont des fans du
rba zh il ya la tis qui a été une
extension qui a eu beaucoup de succès
dont un à la fin des années 90 début des
années 2000 et puis maintenant depuis
une dizaine d'années il ya ggp lot 2 qui
est devenu l'extension de référence pour
faire des graphiques et qui implémentent
la notion de grammaire des graphiques
ce que je veux dire par là c'est que
vous pouvez du coup trouvé sur internet
plusieurs cours différents qui
correspond à des manières de faire
différentes soudeur et moi ce que je
vais vous présenter au travers de ce
webinaire c'est plutôt une certaine
philosophie de r il y en ad'autres pas
dire que la philosophie de r que je
présentais
retrouvez les bons éléments mais en
particulier ce que je vais vous prouver
en particulier on va avoir beaucoup
recours aux tailles diverses
alors le terme tailles diverses
et en fait juste pour vous montrer un
tout ce que je vous dis c'est en fait un
chapitre
d'analyseurs sachets 1
montrer que ce qu'on voit là on peut
retrouver sur la partie support de court
qui est un analyseur donc le taille
diverse et une contraction de taille 10
et de universe en fait c'est une
collection de package qui sont faits
pour travailler ensemble et on va avec
c'est package on va trouver beaucoup de
choses qu'ils vont tourner autour de la
vie de la visualisation de données de la
réalisation de graphiques manipulation
de données import export donné
manipulation de variables et
programmation en fait ils sont issus
d'un travail qui a été initiée par année
wickham et à des webcams aujourd'hui
travaillent pour la société air studio
qui édite notamment l'interface ar
studio alors ce qu'il faut retenir c'est
que
on va au fur et à mesure voir ces
différents package en a à peu près une
vingtaine brune trentaine mais on va
surtout voir au quotidien
ggp lot 2 pour la grammaire des
graphiques et pour faire des graphiques
dipl arias pour la manipulation de
données tide hier qui va nous permettre
à faire de la remise en forme de données
widder va servir à importer des fichiers
texte
fort 4 va nous servir à gérer les dates
qualitative cody sous forme de facteurs
et stringer pas permettre de gérer les
jeunes de caractère on verra que pour
des dates il yad'autres package comme
blue bridge et on va voir au fur et à
mesure ces différents package pour pas
avoir à installer tous les paquets judas
y verse un par un
une manière de le faire de manière
simple c'est d'installer directement un
méta pas qu'il taille diverse
donc si vous retournez dont air dans
package préfère install et ferraille d'y
faire ce en fait installer le package
taille d'hiver permet d'installer
directement tous les autres package du
tailles diverses
de la même manière une fois que le
taille diverse et installer ses vous
faites la brebis tailles diverses
il va automatiquement charge en mémoire
la plupart des package est plus courant
à savoir guy jean claude 2 on l'abordera
dès la semaine prochaine pour faire des
graphiques siebel qui gère à gérer les
tableaux de données tide hier pour la
manipulation de données on l'abordera
plus tôt au mois de janvier
weezer qui va nous permettre d'importer
des fichiers textes dits plat hier pour
la manipulation de données
là encore on est déjà sûr des choses un
petit peu plus avancé qu'on abordera
soit si on a un peu ton qu'on va plutôt
abordé début janvier
mais sachez qu'en une fois je les
apporte tous alors pourquoi je vous dis
ça c'est parce que on va voir notamment
que pour importer des données que ce
soit des fichiers textuelle des fichiers
excel ou des fichiers de logis de
statistiques sas stata ou spss on peut
avoir recours aux fonctions de base de r
notamment un package qui s'appelle
foreign soit aux tailles diverses et
donc moi ce que je vais vous présenter
c'est plutôt le taille diverse par
sculptait diverses intègre proprement
dans un studio parce que tailles
diverses règles un certain nombre de
problèmes qu'on avait historiquement
avec les fonctions historiques de r et
parce que ça permet d'avoir surtout d un
port qui sont uniformisés c'est à dire
qu'on va bien avoir quelque chose de
cohérent que peu importe qu'on apporte à
ficher instat à un fichier texte ou un
fichier excel
alors aujourd'hui pour ce tout premier
webinar on va pas encore voir comment
importer des fichiers stata ou des
fichiers saas ou des fichiers sains spss
parce que pour pouvoir faire ça on va
avoir besoin de voir des choses des
choses un petit peu plus évolué donc
pour ces encore là on en reparlera avec
les données dhabi lisez plutôt
au début de l'année prochaine par contre
on va au moins voir comment apporter un
fichier texte dans sa version de base et
vous allez voir c'est relativement
facile ce que je vais faire un pur
du coup on va juste
voir rapidement comment importer un
fichier texte
et pour ça on va déjà retournés sur
analyse r
et je vais aller dans le
à pitre importe de donner pour aller
télécharger un fichier texte qui va nous
servir d'exemple
vous devez juste henry
le lien sous
pour récupérer ce fichier texte que je
vais mettre sur mon bureau
on va retourner dans leur studio est
alors le plus simple pour importer des
fichiers c'est d'utiliser les outils
coeur studio met à notre disposition en
particulier peut-être que certains
d'entre vous ont déjà vu ici le bouton
hymne porz dataset
alors quand je clique dessus je vais
avoir des options from texte base donc
bah c'est pour dire avec les fonctions
historiques de air ou from tex willer et
widder ces deux fichiers d'un port de
fichiers textes du paquet schlague
diverses
je vais cliquer sur oui d'heure parce
que les options sont plus simples à
utiliser le fer bronze ici pour aller
chercher mon fichier que j'ai mis on l'a
vu sur mon bureau
et la première chose qui se passe et qui
si l'assistant va me faire un preview
une prévisualisation de mon fichier
texte importés ce qui est important à
retenir c'est que quand on apporte un
fichier texte et d'un il peut être
importé les on peut séparer les
variables avec davy recul avec des
tabulations ya plein de manières
différentes de locaux d ela en fait
c'est un fichier texte en fait qui est à
buller et par des faux airs importe avec
comme des limiteurs une virgule non mais
je peux cliquer sur table
dire monde et limiteur c'est à dire ce
qui sépare les différentes valeurs ce
sont des tabulations et là je vois
automatiquement le résultat que ça peut
avoir sur mon apport de la même manière
ici je vois que mes variable textuel
elles sont entourées de guillemets
simple donc ici l'option pot's je vais
la passer sur singh
kimani
bien les valeurs techspace entouré de
kim est simple et voyez on voit de
nouveau une prévision du résultat de
l'import mon résultat
je veux le mettre dans un objet que je
vais appeler
la plaie données
d'accord l'option
type est une option qui permet de dire
je ne veux pas prendre les premières
lignes de caractères on va pas voir
toutes les options d'apport aujourd'hui
c'est juste pour couzier quand même les
premiers éléments de base ce qui peut
être important pour vous c'est local
donc locale s'est tous les éléments qui
sont tour delà de deux particularités
géographiques aux régionales par exemple
sur des dates qui sont français
vous pouvez apprécier ces autres
fichiers est encodé en utf-8 ou en iso
88 59 un pourvoi la différence 1 si
j'avais dit que l'encodage t28 de l'iso
88,1 un rapport on obtient ici oui mais
accents sont remplacés par des choses un
petit peu particulière à la et non il
faut trouver le bon format d'encodage
des accents qui correspond à votre cas
de figure
il ya pas
un de retenir
les éléments que vous avez ici regarder
directement un lien pour accéder à une
aide
si je clique ici
plus ça me renvoie sur le site web du
package rider sur lequel vous avez une
antisèche et sur laquelle on va pouvoir
retrouver tous les éléments avec
overview qui va vous présenter de
manière générale comment faire et vous
pourrez du coup trouvé au fur et à
mesure faire des choses de plus en plus
compliqué souvent on a besoin juste de
connaître le fonctionnement de base d'un
certain nombre de package ou de fonction
et puis enfin vous avez ici un code
preview d'accord donc là il faudrait
trouver le bon élément ce que me fais
cette fenêtre ça me génère le code
nécessaire pour
apporter mes données j'ai deux autres
sion si je clique ici la voyez la petite
icône en forme de presse papier de bloc
notes ça va copier en mémoire le code et
je pourrais aller après leur coller
ailleurs et je peux cliquer sur comme
celle pour annuler si je fais hymne
porte sam exécute le code dans la
console là pour mon nom je veux pas
exécuter je veux jusqu'aux pieds ce qu
au delà je vais faire comme ça et je
vais aller coller dans mon script le
code puisque je veux quelque chose que
ne pouvoir utiliser au fur et à mesure
et donc là par exemple je vais exécuter
donc la brebis
j'exécute mon code ça a chargé l'objet
donné il a été écrit en mémoire et je
vais pouvoir du coup éventuellement le
visualiser
alors ne vous inquiétez pas dans les
prochaines séances on reviendra plus en
détail sur des subtilités quand on veut
apporter un fichier excel ou quand on va
apporter des données qui viennent
d'autres logiciels pour excel en fait
c'est très simple de la même manière
vous cliquez sur une plateforme
excellent vous donnez votre fichier
excel vous allez voir la preview ça va
être extrêmement facile et concernant
les données plus compliqué qui viennent
de stats à de sas ou de spss on reverra
ça dans quatre cinq séances une fois
qu'on aura abordé des éléments un peu
plus fondamentaux nôtre parce qu'on a
des subtilités sur l'apport de données
sachez aussi pour les informaticiens qui
peuvent être présents que vous pouvez
aussi vous connecter à des bases sql
pour récupérer les données qui viennent
depuis une table sql alors là j'ai créé
mon fichier de données d'accord je vais
juste vous montrer rapidement comment ou
peu l'ag
crit qui me permet d'apporter et du coup
je pourrais à la suite de mon script m
les éléments
qui me permettrait de faire mon analyse
la semaine prochaine on va revenir sur
les bases de langage on va revenir sur
la notion de projet et notamment la
notion de chemin relatifs et chemins
absolue ce qui nous permettra de voir
comment est-ce qu'on sauvegarde nos
données et pour faire les choses se
propre montre où la notion de projet
souhaite surtout souhair studio qu'on
abordera du coup la semaine prochaine là
je voulais vraiment vous donner un
premier aperçu de l'outil vous pouvez
commencer à les faire un petit peu de
prise en main la semaine prochaine une
session qui sera consacré aux bases du
langage
c'est une session que pas forcément la
plus amusante mais c'est une cession qui
est essentiel pour bien comprendre les
bases du langage qui nous servira
complètement pour la suite et notamment
pour essayer de faire une session 1 dans
deux semaines on va aborder
comment faire rapidement des
statistiques descriptives faire des
graphiques de manière simple avec des
premiers outils pour que vous puissiez
avoir les premiers éléments pour
commencer à faire vos propres analyses
alors une des questions qui se posent
c'est combien de séances au total eh
bien écoutez là on aurait de quoi tenir
au moins jusqu'au mois de juin et on va
probablement faire des séances peut-être
encore l'année prochaine
l'idée c'est avant noël est donc juste
en 3 séances une session de foire aux
questions dont quatre séances en tout 1
d'avoir les premiers éléments pour
commencer à faire par soi même de la
statistiques descriptives et des
premiers graphique décisif ensuite à la
rentrée 2021
une autre série de séances pour
commencer à avoir induit un peu plus
finement l'edition comment manipuler les
données
comment faire du rpt codage variable
comment on va convertir des vecteurs
d'un type à l'autre comment on peut
restructurer nos données et puis aborder
la régression logistique et par la suite
au cours de l'année on va arriver sur
des séances vers les analyses plus
complexes une fois qu'on aura vu la
régression logistique bas comme on va
faire une sélection pas-à-pas
descendante d'un modèle pour pouvoir
minimiser
c'est l'épreuve de multipolarité comme
ont représenté un graphique de
coefficient ce qu'on appelle un forest
belote
et puis après abordés l'analyse de
survie l'analyse factorielle la
classification ascendante hiérarchique
l'analyse de séquences en fait on a
suffisamment de matériel pour voir des
méthodes analyse plus avancé l'idée
c'est en tout cas
avant noël d'avoir quelques séances
rapide pour une introduction à l'outil
et voir l'analyse descriptive à partir
de janvier revoir des éléments de
manipulation un peu plus poussée revenir
sur la grammaire des graphiques la
gestion des dates la gestion du texte et
la régression logistique et puis ensuite
sur mars avril mai juin
aller vers des choses plus compliquées
au fur et à mesure et d'autres méthodes
statistiques et après on verra comment
comment webinaire fonctionne sur la
durée et éventuellement essayer de
varier
je sais pas je pense à françois briatte
qui pourrait peut-être nous faire une
petite session sur le square ping
l'analyse de réseaux bref l'idée va être
en tous cas par la suite d'aller vers
des choses de plus en plus complexes
écoutez il me semble que ça fait déjà
beaucoup beaucoup de choses pour cette
toute première journée cette toute
première séance
merci à vous je vous invite vraiment du
coup à vous rendre sur le site sur le
site analyseur pour aller compléter
relire à tête reposée différents
éléments
c'est vrai que c'est beaucoup de choses
une des difficultés de r c'est qu'il ya
un petit coup d'entrée faut rentrer dans
un langage programmation pour entrer
dans la logique
sachez en tout cas que ça vaut la peine
une fois qu'on aura passé les premières
séances de base sur le langage
vous allez voir qu'on va pouvoir faire
des choses complètement beaucoup plus
avancé beaucoup plus intéressante on
peut faire des rapports automatisés avec
un macd à aulnoye pouvoir faire des
graphiques extrêmement compliqué on va
pouvoir automatisée des analystes ont
refait un intervalle régulier voilà là
on reste on moment sur des choses qui
restent qui reste simple mais mais on va
essayer d'aller sur des choses plus
compliquées par la suite
dans tous les cas vous n'êtes pas obligé
de suivre toutes les séances et vous
pouvez tout à fait faire des séances en
fonction de vos besoins au cas par cas
quoi qu'il en soit merci pour vous très
bonne fin de soirée et je vous dis à la
semaine prochaine pour un nouveau
webinaire au revoir